Aye. This is real late. Well, I guess, yeah, you got to do this for life.
I heard you say it is important to think I heard Jocko say this too.
How do you think meaning, how do you talk to yourself?
Do you ask yourself questions? Do you think by talking to others,
what do you believe is the most valuable method for becoming a clear thinker and
communicator?
Okay,
that's a deep question. I actually think it's pretty easy to answer.
It is easy answer. I think I can answer in one word. Go Detach.
That's, that's, that's how I think. You can't, you gotta step out.
You've gotta step back mentally. You've got to step back,
look at what's going on and think, and that's where you can think about it.
That's where you can figure out what's going on. If you can do that,
you're there. If you can't do it, you don't even know you're not doing it.
That's the problem. When you're not detached,
you don't even know you're not detached.
You're in the storm and you don't even know it. That's the job for,
that's exactly right. I, but I think, you know,
for people that maybe don't fully understand what that means, right?
[inaudible] this idea of detachment,
which you've obviously talked a lot about on here and which is such a key thing
for decision making. It's the, the,
I think the key thing there is, is to make sure that you're not,
you're not clouded by, you know, this emotional attachment to plans,
which we often talk about with our leaders in the seal teams.
So I'm emotionally invested in a plan that I came up with.
I spent hours or days or weeks or months, you know, involved in, uh, and,
and I want that to succeed of course, but, but is that, you know,
I got to have that realistic assessment and that's what the detachment really
requires is that you pull yourself not just physically away out of the weeds or
to say, okay, let me think about this in a strategic picture. But you really,
you take away that emotional investment that you have to,
to maybe even whether it's a plant, sometimes it's a team member as well.
And if you have, you know,
someone that you just have a close relationship with that you, you know,
whether they're a relative of yours or you had a longstanding relationship with,
and that maybe you've gotten too close to them and you can't see that, that,
you know,
they become more important than the mission and they're dragging the rest of the
team down.
You're not making the call either tighten them up or let them go if that's,
that's the right case.
So I think what that really requires is you got to emotionally pull back.
It's a, it's a, it's a mental thing to,
to really have a brutally honest assessment of the situation. Uh, that's,
that's independent from any kind of, uh, previous bias that you might've had.
That's interesting though, because even if you know, like, Oh yeah,
I'm going to detach. Oh, that's not that easy. Yeah.
Like you gotta go through the motions. You can't be like, Hey,
I'm going to detach. I'm detached right now. Meanwhile, you're just like, I,
you said clouded by the emotional part that you're like kind of one foot in
emotionally, so you're technically not detached. So it doesn't work.
You know what else is a good way to think is to listen to us in what people are
saying. I've been thinking about how more, how he said, if you listen,
you know twice as much.
You know everything that you know when you know everything that the other guy,
yeah, that's a great, that's a great thing.
But if you're sitting in a conversation, I mean from a business perspective,
if you're in a meeting and there's a conversation going on,
if you're in the conversation, you're talking, you're adding your piece,
well then you're, you're not detached, you're in it.
But if you sit back and you listen and you hear what's going on,
you can assemble, you know, thoughts better.